the rehearsals alone or something to
save her for you Jeff Chuck later today
Juan vasila celebrated bass-baritone
from the National Opera House in
Ljubljana will be performing in his home
village shmeh really a shock and what
better venue then the idyllic church of
st. Roch overlooking the village in
eastern Slovenia yosef truck is in
charge of his villages cultural program
the Arts Center has recently been
completely revamped to impressive effect
and not just because of its expansive
library the Cochrane among disabilities
options giggle we could never have done
it just with local funding the village
council wouldn't have agreed to have our
money being spent exclusively on the
cultural center that's why the subsidies
are so vital member in bresnick Roberto
fatigue on every below in addition to
the library the village now also has a
concert hall a modern theatre and a
cinema because the mayor apply for all
manner of EU funding yeah the Thor says
okay Natalie long we've already made a
lot of public buildings energy efficient
and now it's the library's term it'll
cost a little over 100,000 euros if most
of which will be covered by the EU
little skill Nia schmale apply yell
shark has been busy making the most of
the new opportunities and funds
available ever since Slovenia joined the
EU the mayor shows us around the brand
new kindergarten which features spacious
playgrounds and cutting-edge
energy-saving technology Brussels
covered more than two-thirds of the
construction costs although securing
that financial support did require
overcoming a few obstacles
missing there's a lowes a therapist
topic it was really difficult and mainly
because of the Slovenian government not
the EU slovenia dodge there's a bit too
much bureaucracy but we managed it with
determination and persistence finest o
Sadat said Dada la vez eshtebah miracle
and the village is still battling for
further assistance it's joined forces
with five other villages to launch a new
water supply system part of the funding
they need was promised by the Slovenian
government but with the country still
not fully recovered from the economic
crisis the money has not been made
available mama shanna cottage ah yes the
villages had to put up the final
installment from our own budget and now
we have an order to deal with but we
hope the issue will be resolved soon
Luis any additional weddings are always
a sign of optimism and in schmatte ypres
yell shocked people also believe their
marriage with Europe is a happy one
slovenia as a whole still appears eager
to play the model student role well
behaved and eager to impress most people
in the country are pleased to be in the
EU not that they'd forgotten when times
were tough here in SH Mario Puyol shock
just five years ago the village was
languishing under high unemployment and
limited opportunities since then however
a range of new businesses have set up
shop here Masuka
veg it can't be perfect but a lot of
things are better veg tour but again
it's slightly go naked there's a lot of
renovation work the new mayors more
active my reg to donate yes it's good
but eventually we're going to have to
pay it all back well vinko boot has been
telling farmers in his cooperative not
to become dependent on cheap loans from
Brussels and to have more confidence in
their own potential pharmacy largely
produce milk meat and wine tona voltage
is among those who have made substantial
investments based not just on EU funding
but above all on sound judgment so far
successfully as voyeur posilutely
modernization is okay we can't farm like
we did 30 or 50 years ago but but
neither do we have to immediately match
the levels of Germany for example the
moderation is the best strategy dr.
Molina but that seems to be paying off
for the residents of schmatte Ypres yell
shocked big supporters of the EU and not
solely for pragmatic reasons
and there are further plans afoot for
new cycle paths an eco-friendly swimming
pool and a golf course and at sunset the
church fills up with villagers arriving
for the concert inch Madhya Pradesh
Jacques a village with a bright future